remember Sprint 10 to 15 years ago
Sprint was one of the big three telecom
companies along with AT&T and Verizon
they had tens of millions of subscribers
and were pulling in tens of billions of
dollars every year but by the end of the
2010s the picture looked a lot different
Not only was print bleeding subscribers
and revenue but they were being shown up
by a new player T-Mobile T-Mobile had
risen From the Ashes of near bankruptcy
and was making name for themselves as
the uncarrier everything that you hated
about cell phone plans and carriers
T-Mobile was trying to eliminate no more
contracts no more hidden fees and no
more sleazy salesmen and this pitch
worked it worked really well actually
within just a few years T-Mobile would
grow from being a distant player behind
Sprint to trying to acquire the entirety
of Sprint this was definitely a punch to
the gut for Sprint and likely a deal
that they did not want to accept
but looking inwards at the fundamentals
of Sprint it was obvious that T-Mobile
was making a generous offer and turning
it down would be a disservice to
shareholders so in 2018 Sprint would
agreed to a 26.5 billion deal with
T-Mobile it took a few years to actually
finalize the deal and get it through
Regulators but eventually on April 1st
2020 T-Mobile would complete their
acquisition of Sprint at first there was
some hope that maybe T-Mobile would keep
around these branding and just operated
as a subsidiary like they did with Boost
Mobile but T-Mobile immediately moved to
wipe away all remnants of Sprint and
just a few months after the acquisition
on August 2nd 2020 the Sprint brand
would be officially discontinued with
the help of Sprint T-Mobile has become
the largest Telecom company in the US
and revenue has exploded to a new tier
so things are going better than ever for
T-Mobile but the same cannot be be said
about Sprint if you try accessing
sprint.com you're met with this sad
landing page that just redirects you to
T-Mobile's website but how did this
happen how did Sprint go from being one
of the big three telecom companies to
being completely erased off the face of
the planet within a matter of just 10
years well join me as we take a look
back at the rise and fall of the
Forgotten giant
[Music]
Sprint
Sprint was obviously Left Behind largely
because of their unwillingness to change
with the times their story is
particularly interesting because unlike
their peers they didn't come from a
monopolistic background if you didn't
know AT&T and ryzen both evolved from
the original AT&T which as a repeat
controlled 90% of the US telephone
business similarly T-Mobile has very
much benefited from the backing of
Deutsche Telecom Germany's national
Telecom carrier Sprint however has
always been the underdog as the story of
Sprint dates back to 1899 to the rural
town of abalene Kansas to a man named
clayon Leroy Brown clayon was the son of
Jacob Brown a local Grist Mill owner
usually this would have led to a pretty
nice upbringing but unfortunately for
clayon his father's meal turned out to
be his worst nightmare as he would lose
his arm to a male accident when he was
just 10 years old clayon didn't let this
accident wear him down though he would
go on to be a teacher and a manager at a
creary before opening a local electric
company it was around this time the
telephones first started to make their
appearance Across the Nation and when it
came to telephones there was really only
one option the Bell Telephone company or
AT&T the local people of abene weren't
exactly a fan of this as they much
preferred supporting a local businessman
as opposed to some national giant so at
the community's request clayon would
establish the brown Telephone Company in
1899 and this brings us into the first
key strategy of Sprint Customer Loyalty
and connection the reason that the brown
telephone company was successful was not
because they had insane resources or
some sort of groundbreaking technology
no the reason the brown telephone
company was successful was because they
had a personal connection with their
customers and their customers were
rooting for their Victory it was the
same strategy that T-Mobile capitalized
on over aund years later with their
whole carrier movement customers were
rooting for T-Mobile to redefine the
carrier landscape and clean the space
the same however could not be said about
the modern Sprint most customers didn't
have a particularly positive or negative
view on Sprint but they were only using
Sprint for one main reason because it
made Financial sense Sprint gave them a
good deal or a strong discount which got
them in the door when that initial promo
ended though people would simply leave
in other words words Sprint had very
little customer connection and loyalty
and this really hurt them all of the new
customers that they were getting were
money losers and right when they tried
to convert them into profitable
customers they would just leave the best
way to overcome this Pitfall is to give
customers a reason to stick around
that's not just purely Financial or
logical similar to what T-Mobile or the
brown telephone company did without this
sort of X Factor though Sprint simply
became the place that Savvy customers
farmed deals which eventually made the
company
[Music]
unviable fortunately things were looking
much better for clayon brown back in the
day clayon never had aspirations of
growing some sort of national Giant in
fact he much preferred to run a variety
of different local businesses after
founding the brown telephone company for
example clayon opened up shoe stores
grocery stores a gravel and sand company
hotels a new service a broadcast station
insurance companies and oil companies as
you can see clayon was much more of a
multifaceted businessman as opposed to
being a magnate in any one sector but
this didn't mean that he squandered
growth opportunities that did come his
way in fact he was very much known for
his consolidation and expansion skills
in 1911 for example he merged the brown
telephone company with three other local
telephone companies to create the United
telephone company and in 1925 he would
further consolidate to create the United
telephone and Electric Company Sprint
very much kept up this tradition of
strong mergers and Acquisitions while
past clayon days and this brings us into
their second key strategy strategic
deals this is precisely how Sprint grew
from being a regional phone business to
being a national giant consistently
making better and better deals for
example in 1986 Brown's company would
make a groundbreaking deal with Southern
Pacific Communications or SPC they would
agree to merge with SPC and to create a
new joint venture called Sprint which
stands for Southern Pacific Railroad
internal networking telepon similarly in
1993 Sprint would emerge with a cellular
business called sentel which gave them
access to the wireless market and in
1996 they would strike a deal with Radio
Shack to open up Sprint stores inside
Radio Shacks those were just a few of
Sprint's most notable deals they've
completed dozens of such deals and
that's how they really grew their naal
presence but not all of their deals had
such a happy ending which brings us into
their deal with nextail Communications
in 2004 Sprint announced that they would
be merging with nexttel Communications
at the time Sprint was the third largest
player and nexile was the fifth largest
player within the mobile phone industry
so on paper it seemed that this merger
would make this Duo Unstoppable but see
there's more to a successful merger than
just size for a merger to be be
successful both parties need to have
significant synergies that can benefit
from each other for example maybe Sprint
had strong networks in the East while
Nexel had strong networks in the west
together they could have a strong
Nationwide network but that's not how
things quite played out you see not only
did Sprint and Nextel not have many
synergies but they actually had a bunch
of opposing technologies that could not
be combined as such if these companies
wanted to streamline and consolidate
their networ Works they often had to
choose between the two companies
Holdings rendering the merger completely
useless to make things worse their
integration efforts often led to outages
and cell phone plans simply not working
all together so not only did the merger
not allow them to reach new heights but
it made them look bad in front of their
existing customers Sprint would
eventually write off almost the entirety
of Nexel in 2008 as a$ 29.5 billion loss
and they would shut down the company
altogether in 2013
having wasted a full decade and tens of
billions on this deal Sprint had fallen
far behind AT&T and Verizon when it came
to network coverage and reliability and
this leads us into their eventual
Demise by the time that Sprint shut down
next things were looking pretty bleak
they had a subpar Network paired with
bruised morale unloyal customers and an
empty balance sheet but honestly you
could argue that T-Mobile was in an even
worse position in fact T-Mobile wasn't
even allowed to sell iPhones till 2013
yet they were able to do this over the
next 10 years so Sprint was by no means
a lost cause they definitely still had a
chance to recover but staging such a
recovery requires one key characteristic
humility this was one of the strong
suits of clayon he didn't live a
particularly long life having passed
away at age 63 but but despite that he
spent the latter half of his life giving
back to the community that had given him
everything in 1926 for example he built
a memorial foundation in memory of his
parents he would also go on to build a
200 acre park for free which included an
amusement park a lake a zoo a golf
course tennis courts and more of course
this has no direct link to business but
at the same time it does humility is
extremely important when it comes to
running a business it turns out that
customers are surprisingly understanding
when you're honest about a shortcoming
instead of trying to hide it or deceive
them about it again this is precisely
what T-Mobile leveraged they admitted
that they sucked they didn't have the
best service that was simply a fact
however they were working on fixing this
and while they couldn't promise you the
best service right now what they could
promise was an honest transparent
relationship something that you couldn't
get from the big players it would have
been in Sprint's best interest to
leverage a similar strategy but their
ego rendered this virtually impossible
Sprint approached the situation with the
ego of a national giant as far as they
were concerned they were still the big
dog that was just facing a temporary
downfall as such they thought that they
could just pretend that they weren't
inferior to AT&T and Verizon and that
they could just incentivize themselves
out of the situation you know by
offering strong discounts and deals that
were too good to refuse but as we
discussed this just led to net negative
customers were only there for the
incentives which is really not
surprising after all we're talking about
a carrier that came with all of the same
shortfalls as AT&T and ryzen you know
the 2-year contracts the hidden fees and
the sleazy salespeople but on top of
this the network wasn't even good either
meaning that the only reason to stick
around was for financial incentives so
trying to buy out customers using
incentives wasn't exactly a great
long-term strategy but that wasn't even
the worst part the worst part was that
since Sprint never really admitted that
they had a problem they never addressed
their shortcomings for example they
decided against building traditional
cell phone towers for some reason
similarly they were relatively late to
5G something that T-Mobile was early to
and when you combine this lack of
customer loyalty with a botch deal
that's Weighing on the company and a
general unwillingness to admit
shortcomings and overcome them Sprint's
fate was sealed long before T-Mobile
actually took over and put them down for
good if you would like to see how
T-Mobile managed to do what Sprint
couldn't check out this video but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next
one